whoa uh who do you have on this uh
project that's coming out Friday uh
Gotti
baby
the
uh
who was like a gotti baby duck
who else who I'm listening
while uh we just had Rallo here last
week oh and yeah static me no static
mage of course it's Kentucky Legend rest
in peace yeah I got something static how
do you
get the vocals
static at one million songs I've heard
I've heard he has like a like a crazy
hard drive of unreleased stuff that
people like drives drives yeah
so do you go through his family like do
you go through like how do you get the
static major
that's crazy
it's it's crazy too because we don't
really like uh
yeah he's one of the more prolific
songwriters you know
and like I feel like his influence is
like never really like
acknowledge like it should be I won't
say they just opened up a static major
exhibit in Louisville wow
finally you feel me yeah are they
working or did they open it already
I think they trying to work on it up is
he on is it a verse or is it hook for me
um
playing for your own says but it's he's
all over the song Oh that's fire that's
dope when you get that like like tell me
the process do they like let you come
and like you you're playing with my P
with ain't no I'm saying but like like
let's say it's your people right are you
able to kind of like go through a few
joints on the drive and be like I like
this one or like this one or they send
it to you like hey this one you can have
this one does that make sense they know
I ain't you know what I'm saying that's
what we see this
she's musically inclined right A lot of
people hit up for Stuff Drake you know
what I'm saying was it on on the
original beat that it was cut on or did
you take the vocals and put on UB
she got the beat together with her
people and then you know I'm saying
asked me
what I change if I was like I just
wanted to let her do her thing so
I'm saying static and
re-emerge he never left but just kind of
get more introduced to I'm saying it is
kind of crazy because like if we think
about like Louisville and Kentucky
overall like you guys want to like a run
right now you know
I mean
Bryson yourself Jack Harlow
I feel like you guys didn't really have
too much of like a real national
identity but I feel like you in
particular have really like represented
like a side of Louisville that like we
never really got to see through a guy
like Bryson because he's obviously a r b
singer so you know for you like how
important is that for you to still kind
of like
make sure you're
kind of carry in the state make sure
you're representing the state nationally
make sure you represent the city you
know what I'm saying I don't feel no
pressure it's just
me I got
I know a lot of people you like to break
it up with Bryson dragons but at this
point I feel like we gotta stop breaking
it up because if we're going off sales
and accolades and stuff like
I'm like the guy yeah you know what I'm
saying and um got no gimmicks or no
funny [__] with me I just dropped the
music yeah my life and I got
stats to prove not no [__] are in the
barbershop about who's better I got gold
Plex Platinum Plex that's a lead artist
you know what I'm saying it's a big deal
you got a gold album the entire album
it's a big deal man so I
I don't know I feel like it's it they
shouldn't jumble it up and say this type
of music this type like artists I feel
like I'm the
leading the Forefront of you know saying
rap in general not just Louisville I was
gonna say what market for you started to
pick up on estg first outside of
Louisville like what was like that City
you were like oh this is spreading this
is moving somewhere like I could
actually go get a bag in this place like
was there a city that you remember that
like really kind of like
it was all at the same time kind of like
it just kind of all kind of happened
like wildfire quick I just was moving
around anyway so
people knew me not the streets knew me
anyway yeah they come with the music and
we pop up 80 [__] 80 chains 80 watches
it don't matter what if you're getting
up Brian humming you know what I'm
saying yeah they're gonna they won't see
what you talking about